there's not a better place in Las Vegas
for the jackpot New Year's Eve Music
Festival featuring some of the biggest
names in electronic music and here to
tell us all about it we have Joe
boreshowitz thank you so much for being
here Joe thank you for having me really
appreciate it exciting and you guys have
quite the lineup let's jump right to it
tell us about the festival we do so
jackpot is a brand new music festival on
New Year's weekend here in Las Vegas
it's kind of unlike anything else going
on in the city during that weekend it's
located right in the center of downtown
Las Vegas like you mentioned it has some
of the biggest names in electronic music
all together on the same lineup over two
days we're talking Festival style Stage
production pyrotechnics our own
dedicated fireworks show it's kind of
got everything wow that is awesome and
you don't have just one night to
experience it you guys are doing two
nights right we're doing two nights
there's 14 artists to see over the
course of both nights we're selling two
day passes or one days for people who
can't make it both nights well you guys
are really going big for New Year's Eve
it's so fun out here in Las Vegas now
you guys are kind of just taking it up
to the next level can you tell us some
of the names of who will be performing
100 I mean Vegas is always a party
destination on New Year's weekend but
we've never really had a destination
sort of Music Festival kind of like some
other the big Metro markets have so we
felt like it was time to introduce that
into the city we're locals here so you
know we felt it was an important part of
the landscape to sort of add in as far
as the lineup you've got household names
like dead mouse res Porter Robinson RL
Grime but we also put a lot of time into
curating the rest of the bill we wanted
it to be diverse there's so many genres
of music you know under the electronic
umbrella that whatever you like to dance
to we wanted to make sure we had
something for you at Jackpot and I think
this is a really cool because we all see
you know a lot of these performers at
the nightclubs and at those venues but
now we get to see them outside of there
and I bet it's just such a different
experience but what else I think is cool
is that you guys also support emerging
artists so can we expect to see some new
up-and-coming names at the festival too
absolutely I mean to your first point
yeah a lot of these guys come through
the nightclub circuit but the vibe to
expect that our events is completely
different there's no velvet ropes
there's no strict dress codes we just
encourage everyone to come as they are
just to enjoy you know in their Festival
attire their comfortable shoes if they
want to
um to that point yeah I mean on the
lineup we have kind of all levels of
artists some of the more emerging names
I would say there's an artist called
Rossi making a lot of really cool music
these days she's going to be playing on
night two sort of setting the stage
we're looking forward to it hey you had
me at comfortable shoes that's the way
to go when you have a long night ahead
of you and fireworks it sounds like it's
going to be such a party and also a lot
of work have you guys been putting in a
lot of time and effort to make this kind
of above and beyond it's sort of been
our lives for the last four or five
months but you know we're looking
forward to it all paying off it's a
labor of love oh a layer of love I love
that and a lot to see a lot to
experience of
if you're available at jackpotnye.com
like I said we have two day passes
single day passes for people who want a
more elevated experience we are offering
bottle service options various price
points lots of ways to dial in your
experience well I'm so excited jackpot
is the perfect name for this and thank
you so much for being here Joe I hope
that this becomes a tradition in our
city every year absolutely do thank you
for having me all right be sure to check
out the